on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook is one of the most
powerful explosive and controversial
figures in World sport Dana White one on
one No Holds Barred and definitely
uncensored
[Music]
good evening from London welcome to a
special edition of Piers Morgan
unscented a box office one-on-one
interview with UFC president Dana White
he's the man who turned a Bloodsport
into a business worth billions of
dollars UFC Supremo Dana White took
mixed martial arts into the stratosphere
making superstars of Fighters like Conor
McGregor
from trouble Roots he worked as a paver
a bouncer and a Bellboy before becoming
one of the most powerful men in World
sport
these famous friends like Donald Trump
is sold out shows and distinctly
uncensored press conferences wait what
do you have a question about the fight
who these guys are fighting or you just
want to start near Dana White is a
magnet for headlines and controversy
he's been slammed over Fighters paying
for his vice like grip on the sporty
transformed
this fractures incident with his wife on
New Year's Eve sparked a global Fury
he's revered feared hated adored but
absolutely never ignored and tonight
Dana White is uncensored
well I'm joined Now by Dana White Dane
I've got to say that when my three sons
who are all mad UFC fans when they heard
I was interviewing you I don't think
I've ever heard them either more excited
about a guest or prouder of their father
so for that alone thank you
well thank you and tell them thanks for
the support I took them all to the big
uh McGregor Mayweather fight down in
Vegas which presumably lined your
pockets in the process um and it wasn't
probably a perfect example of what
you're about really it was an incredible
theater it involved two supreme Champion
Fighters albeit in different disciplines
and I found it a riveting thing to watch
albeit it ended how I suspected it was
always going to end uh but that to me in
a nutshell was you all over Vegas high
drama High theater
specialist pugilists at their very best
and a kind of unique encounter
yeah what we try to do is try to give
the best experience that we can for fans
either live or on television it's it's
uh it's the thing that I focus on the
most when you come to a live UFC event
or an event that we're putting on
most people don't walk out and say yeah
I don't ever want to see one of these
again the thing that is intriguing about
you to me is where you came from to get
to where you've got to when you look
back at your journey you know you were
born in 1969 to a 19 year old high
school dropout mum you had a 21 year old
alcoholic father who left the home I
think when you were seven or eight years
old uh you you worked your way through
some pretty tough early years uh had no
Silver Spoon no great privilege and yet
here you are now sitting here talking to
me to miss Jim and you've got a
multi-billion dollar business that's
made you both extremely rich very
successful but I'd imagine also for you
yourself that Journey must be incredibly
satisfying
yeah it's it's been uh it's been amazing
actually you know as I as I look back
on my life and and you know where I
started and where I am today it's it's
it's been amazing but I I love it so
much that you know I'm 54 I just turned
54 years old and in July and uh you know
I feel like I haven't I haven't even
scratched the surface of of what's left
to do in in this business and in this
sport but it's it's definitely been an
incredible journey you're a road paver a
bouncer a hotel Bellman and an
apprentice boxing joint and you've done
a few things in your in your time when
you were doing those things did you have
a big dream
yeah well I think I think when you're
young those are all the type of jobs you
have to you have to do number one to
find out what hard work really is and
number two to find out what it is you
don't want to do in life so I was very
lucky that I had all those experiences
and by the age of 19 I figured out
didn't want to do any of that and I knew
exactly what I wanted to do I wanted to
be in the fight business which at the
time you know uh was 1988 or 1989
sounded like the dumbest idea ever but
um when you love
something and you're very passionate
about it you know and you know exactly
what it is you want to do you just get
up every day and start grinding until
until it happens
you come from an Irish Catholic uh
background as I do and you also you were
taught by nuns when you're younger as I
was I had spiritual guidance from nuns
how did that impact you
I don't know that you know
um
you know went to Catholic school and and
uh and you know had to go to church and
all that stuff growing up I was an altar
boy when I was younger
uh I don't know how that I don't know if
that uh
affected me in in a positive way toward
religion but uh you know I'm not a very
religious person these days I would say
I
it's weird because there's some things
that I don't believe in much but I
believe in karma for some reason uh
I never really was Guided by religion in
any way shape or form as I got into my
20s what do you think happens to you
when you die
I think that it's it's it's it's it
it's over there is I think that we think
we're more important than we really are
because some people have to believe that
to get through life I'm not one of those
people that has to believe that
um listen maybe there is maybe there
isn't I'd say the the real answer for me
is I don't know
but I don't let that guide me and I
don't let it uh you know just be a good
person you you can figure out being a
good person without having to uh believe
in anything in my opinion your
relationship with your parents obviously
complicated difficult
um I know you don't particularly like
talking about that I don't want to pry
into into that other than to just ask
whether
it's had a material effect on you as a
person do you think a lot of the drive
that you have comes from those
difficulties and those difficult
relationships
you're right I don't like talking about
it but it's a great question and and I
would say yes absolutely my relationship
with my parents has has definitely uh
you know
made me who I am today in many different
ways not just you know in life and in
business but as a father too so I
wouldn't change my upbringing
not one thing about it I wouldn't change
any of it so
um
yeah great question and I agree with you
has it made you a better father yourself
do you think a better parent 100
but my parents taught me a lot about
what I didn't want to be as a parent and
uh
yeah
and I don't really talk about I don't
think I've ever talked about this but my
parents both died recently so
um
that yeah so that's that's uh
yeah I don't like talking about it but
yeah my parents died recently and and uh
how does that make you feel given how
difficult things have been
um holy this is where we're going
with this interview huh I uh
I uh I I don't know you know
I'm good with it I'm good with
everything you know I I focus a lot on
my kids and and uh my relationship with
them and I've sort of put my
relationship with my parents behind me
did you feel sad when you knew they died
or did you feel it was the end of it no
I
didn't wish any ill will on either one
of my parents but you know no I I didn't
when they passed away I I had uh
I had almost no no feelings about it to
be honest with you you didn't go to the
funeral funerals I was rather
yeah listen I took care of my I took
care of my father and and uh moved him
up to Maine and and
you know put him to rest with his family
up there and then my mother I had
nothing to do with any of hers her
family handled uh you know her when she
passed away
I mean it's obviously it's an
extraordinarily sad part of your life
and obviously I didn't know that your
parents had both died recently and I
thank you for sharing that a very
private information I appreciate it but
I am curious as to you acknowledge the
drive that you have a lot of that may
have come from this quite rough time you
had but do you do you feel a great loss
that you didn't have
the love of your parents that many other
people take for granted
you sound like my wife uh
what
no no I did not feel that way and uh but
there's no doubt about it I I I cannot
deny the fact that the way that I am
built and the way the drive and all the
things that I have uh definitely come
from the relationship that I had with my
parents there's no there's no doubt
about it
um but no I have no remorse I don't feel
bad about the way that I grew up I I
mean it when I say that I wouldn't
change one thing about the way that I
was brought up because I truly believe
uh had I not had them for parents had I
not had the upbringing that I that I did
have that I wouldn't be who I am today
what are the things uh Dana what are the
things that you that it taught you not
to do as a parent and what are the
things that it taught you to do as a
parent
yeah I think that uh you know the the
two Do's is I I'm I'm here for my kids
you know I've been married for almost 30
years you go through you know
a lot of things in a marriage I mean I
just went through some stuff last New
Year's Eve uh you know these things
happen what you don't do is you don't
leave you don't quit you don't give up
and and you stay you know you don't stay
together just for your children but you
stay I made a commitment
22 years ago I had my first son and
there's a commitment there to everybody
that's involved and uh you know I I've
I've stayed in there I'm always there
for my kids anything that they ever need
um
and you know
my father taught me
you know what it feels like to not have
a father there at the house what it's
like to not have that that person around
all the time when you need them and I
would never do that to my kids
you said a great quote you talked about
my legacy to me is when I dropped dead
and my kids are at my funeral I want my
three kids to get up and say he's an
awesome dad
is that ultimately in the end the real
litmus test of success for you I've seen
other people say you know actually if in
the end your your kids when they get old
enough to make that decision for
themselves if they still want to be
around you and they still love you and
they still care about you and they would
speak at your funeral in positive way
about you that in the end that's the
ultimate litmus test of success far more
than any Financial benefits or gains or
fights or whatever it may be
well said I couldn't have said that
better myself you're absolutely right
you know everybody everybody's always
asking about Legacy your legacy what you
did for a living isn't your legacy your
legacy is your children and and their
children and and you know how they feel
about you how they feel about
listen we we all make mistakes and we
all fail in life and many different
things my opinion is the one thing that
you can't fail
is being a parent it's it's it's the
ultimate failure it's the it's it's what
showed that you you really weren't
focused on the right things in your life
if that's what you failed at
when you reference the the incident on
New Year's Eve and obviously it went
viral everyone saw the video footage and
so on you were very contrite after that
um but what's the hardest thing of that
actually having to talk it over with
your kids
100 percent I mean everybody was acting
like there needs to be some big apology
to the world
um no the apology was to my kids for for
me and my wife uh nobody wants to see
their dumb drunk parents slapping each
other on TMZ you know what I mean
our oldest son didn't talk to us for
like four days and
um
you know and and the other kids had to
deal with some stuff too it's
embarrassing and uh the only apology
that needed to be made was to our
children and and the only uh
relationships that needed to be handled
immediately was between us and our kids
and and we did it we handled it and and
we got through it as a family what was
it like for you having seen so many
fighters get into scrapes and having to
deal with the fall out of that what was
it like for you to suddenly be on the
receiving end yourself of that kind of
attention
yeah yeah it's definitely not fun uh but
it's it's something that you know
as a man you have to stand up and you
have to deal with it and and
uh handle your business take your lumps
and and deal with whatever whatever
comes with it and uh but but like I said
the most important part of it is to
handle it as a family first as long as
you get your family straight
I could give a what everybody else
thinks did you worry enduring that whole
episode that you may lose everything
that you'd fought so hard to build
nah uh the people that are around me
again when you're talking about
something like this that happens and
you're talking about the what everybody
else the whole world is looking at you
and saying the people who know me know
me and and and the people that the
circle that I keep I've had for you know
40 years so
um you know the people that that I cared
the most about I I knew it was going to
be whatever everybody else I I could
care less what everybody else thinks
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the special edition of
the show Dana White uncensored
the start of UFC
um because you had a couple of investor
friends they bought the franchise off
you for two million dollars you'd come
to Vegas but how you got to Vegas it's
fascinating because you would basically
chased out of town by the mafia by Mr
Bolger who was of course a very famous
Mafia mobster
um tell me about that
yeah it wasn't him it was some of his
his guys that worked under him but uh
yeah I mean I was in Boston
and uh you know the the early 90s and
and and that stuff was real back then I
mean if you watch any of the movies or
any of the documentaries that came out
about it I lived in South Boston
Massachusetts and and that stuff was
very real and at the time you know they
had felt that I owed them some money
that I felt I didn't know and uh you
know I was either going to pay it or I
or I wasn't going to pay it but right
when I left and came back to Vegas it
was like the summer of 95 and then right
after that is when all the stuff started
to unravel
uh for him and you know he basically
went on the run after that and now I
mean you I was in we had a fight in
Boston a couple weeks ago I mean it's
not even the same city it's it's
completely different and South Boston is
is not the same place it was in the 80s
and early 90s so when I go back there
now and look at it at that place and at
that time
it you know you realize what a scary
place that really was at at that point
in time but I didn't really feel that
way when I was in my early 20s you know
um
yeah I don't know how that would have
played out but I can tell you this I got
the call I hung up the phone picked it
back up and called Delta and got a
one-way ticket back to Vegas and what's
funny is
everything in life is about timing you
know it was the time for me to come back
to Vegas for all of this stuff to align
and to happen so earlier you and I were
just talking about religion and what you
believe and what you don't it's it's
just crazy the way that things work out
and how things are kind of meant to be
and what will
put you on these different paths in life
it's fascinating you've turned a
business that you managed to find two
guys two investor friends to spend two
million dollars buying the UFC franchise
off you but it was a very basic
franchise at the time one octagon and a
few bits and pieces around it today that
business is worth 12 billion dollars
It's Made You incredibly rich in the
process obviously but my simple question
is how how did you do this
yeah so it's a great question yeah when
we originally bought the company for two
million dollars we had a few contracts
when I say a few maybe eight to Fifteen
contracts and an old wooden octagon and
those three letters UFC that was it the
former owner had basically stripped all
the rights and sold everything off to
try to keep the thing alive
um but what we did was we came in we
started to acquire some of these rights
back uh from from other companies that
that had bought them we uh we started to
build you know the the trademark back
and and the brand
and we had a vision for this thing we we
were big fight fans and uh we believed
that if this was done the right way this
could be the biggest sport in the world
uh you know I always have this
philosophy about fighting
that it doesn't matter what color you
are what country you come from what
language you speak we're all human
beings fighting's in our DNA we get it
and we like it it doesn't have to be
explained to anybody and when you have
the right fight in the right place at
the right time like you were just
talking about earlier with Conor
McGregor and Floyd Mayweather everybody
wants to watch it everywhere all over
the world now we're getting to a place
with streaming where that's actually
starting to become possible where we can
put on a fight out here in America and
the whole world can watch it on the same
at the same time on the same network so
the ceiling on this thing is what eight
billion people are in the world as you
continue to grow the sport this thing
can actually become the biggest sport in
the world and we saw that from day one
the question was is the timing right and
thank God it was well there were two
politicians who had interesting takes on
what you were doing in 1996 Senator John
McCain it was a huge boxing fan
but he railed against the UFC on the
floor of the U.S Senate he called it
human cockfighting and he sent letters
to the governor of every state asking
them to ban it
and then Donald Trump came along
right when the whole business may have
been up for grabs it may not have flown
it may just have sunk and Donald Trump
turned up and stayed late at one of your
events and he carried on supporting you
uh and you stayed friends ever since how
important well first of all tell me
about John McCain how did you feel when
he called it basically cockfighting
yeah that happened before we bought the
company so that was one of the uphill
battles that we had obviously Senator
John McCain
did everything for the right reasons he
he wanted this thing to be regulated by
the athletic commission rules in place
and and referees and judges and proper
medical testing and all that stuff we
agreed with Senator John McCain when we
bought the company and we ran toward
regulation and we wanted to get this
thing regulated by all the athletic
commissions uh not only in the country
but throughout the world and then uh
yeah Donald Trump
when we bought the company you know
venues didn't want this there were no
venues that wanted this thing now we
break every venue record all over the
world and and venues everywhere want us
to come but in the beginning nobody did
but Donald Trump saw this thing early
saw that he thought it could be
successful when you think about it the
Trump brand was here the UFC brand was
here and he brought us in cut us a great
deal showed up to the first fight stayed
to the last fight for both of the uh the
events that we put on in his casino and
everything that ever happened to me
throughout the rest of my career Donald
Trump was the first guy to either pick
up the phone and call and say
congratulations or write a note and send
something
um you know he was always that guy then
Donald Trump and his son got in and
actually started to compete with the UFC
so with with another company and you
would always have these you know these
media people trying to put me against
Trump and say oh and my whole thing was
I will never say anything bad about this
guy he was extremely good to me not only
in the early days but throughout the
rest of my career and you know that
that's all that stuff is what started
the incredible relationship that I have
with Donald Trump I mean you know I've
seen the good side of trump and I've
seen the but we've all seen some of the
bad side of him
um you've remained for reasons you've
explained extremely loyal to him how
hard is that sometimes to do that
publicly it's it's not hard as all
because I you know how I judge people is
how my relationship is with them you
know I could I can have a friend that 15
other people don't like for whatever
reason I judge them off their
relationship with me and I can tell you
from personal experience Donald Trump
has never been anything but loyal and
incredible and an amazing friend to me
do you think he can become president
again
uh I do I mean people thought he
couldn't become president the first time
and he did I absolutely think he could
do it again listen
the forces are fighting against him
they're trying to do everything they can
to make sure that this guy uh does not
uh
even have a chance to be elected again
but yes I mean a majority of the country
wants this guy to be the next president
of the United States how often do you
talk to him
I talked to him several times a month I
just talked to him last week
he and I are very close we're very good
friends I consider him a very good
friend of mine and we we talk a lot what
do you talk about
fights he's a fight fan he's a fight
freak he loves fights
um you know mostly what we talk about is
is fights he's a fight fan and uh you
know we talk about other things family
and stuff like that too but mostly we
talk about fights what I really like
about you Dana and your story is that
it's it's a story of resilience of
determination of getting yourself back
on your feet when you've been knocked
down all the kind of Rocky Balboa things
that he says in that Infamous speech or
famous speech to his son who's being a
spoiled brat and he funny has it out
with him in the street I've seen you say
that you think America and probably The
Wider World though she has gone soft and
I agree I think it has gone soft I think
we've become a a world where virtue
signaling is more important than reality
uh where facts no longer matter you can
all pretend to be whatever you want and
everyone has to go along with it
um where everyone's offended by
absolutely everything
um have we got to this place and what's
what's the way out of this kind of woke
hell that we're having to endure
America has become so soft it's it's
actually
you know
it's a problem and
I tell kids all the time if you even
have this much Savage in you everything
out there right now is for the taking
there was a there was a point in time in
the United States where you would look
at at different businesses and say God
it's almost impossible to break into
this business because it's been so
established and even the companies all
these companies that are so soft right
now everything out there is for the
taking if you have even this much Savage
as you if you are willing to go out
there and grind and work hard you know
you got these people that don't want to
go to work they want to stay home and
and work from home and all the and and
believe me I've seen this when I've
spoke before I see it pop up in the
comments all these people saying you're
wrong no things can be done from home no
it can't you have to be in the building
with like-minded people you know how
much stuff that I have on my agenda
every day
um that needs to be done but other
things that pop up in the office and you
get a bunch of of smart hard-working
people in the room together and you go
on a completely different you know
you you have to have people in the
office working every day and these
people that don't want to stay home man
stay home and and do your thing good
luck to you I wish you all the luck in
the world there's going to be a small
group of hungry Savages out there that
are going to run every one of you over
and you can sit home and you can cry and
complain about how you didn't get yours
and it's because this person had this
opportunity that you didn't have it's
all crybaby stuff that's going
on in the whole world like you said but
more so in the United States like I've
never seen before I read a great profile
of You by the financial times and the
the rights are clearly gone in with the
kind of idea that maybe you were going
to be some kind of egotistical monster
whatever but he found the complete
opposite and he told some really
interesting stories one of which was as
you were coming out of the pandemic in
the middle of the pandemic how you got
all your team together 300 people I
think and you said there's absolutely no
way hey I'm gonna start cutting you off
you know firing a lot of people to save
money we're going to get through this
together and apparently the reaction
from your staff was extraordinary
um how important was that moment for you
to prove yourself as a boss in the tough
times as well as the good
yeah uh it's so true it's like you know
the the UFC has been this rocket ship of
success
um since 2005 right and nobody does
anything by themselves you build a great
team around yourself you know you know
smart talented hard-working people who
sacrifice every day uh they didn't see
their kids football game or they didn't
go to this play because they're out
working hard to build the sport and
build the company right now you're gonna
tell me covet comes covet never really
made sense to me uh you know from the
beginning the first day when everything
started to shut down it was getting
weird I got all my employees together
and I said listen
I don't know what's going on I I can't
explain I don't have the answers for you
but if any of you are scared or feel
like you're you know your life is in
danger or somebody at home might be in
danger you guys can go home and do
whatever you have to do my team is a
bunch of of solid uh you know they
couldn't be any more solid and I tell
these people how much I love them all
the time
so what you're going to tell me is the
first time that we ever face adversity
right we're facing real adversity here
I'm gonna start laying these people off
in the scariest time in the history of
the world good luck to you you know we
we gotta save the bottom line over here
I will never pick money over people
so I I was willing to give up my salary
my bonus whatever it was going to take
to make sure that everybody was
comfortable that we could take care of
the employees and then I started trying
to find a way to go through covet don't
this is America
we we've been doing this since the day
this country started is solving problems
you have to figure out
here's the problem how's there a
solution now in Abu Dhabi
these guys were way ahead of the curve
they were testing they were doing all
this stuff well if they can test we can
test we can figure this out so that was
always my thought process going through
it there was no way I was going to let
go of my employees during the scariest
time of our lifetime you talked about
Abu Dhabi there in the Middle East
um and you're a big fan of a lot of what
goes on in the Middle East particularly
in sport and other things they're
obviously getting more and more dominant
now in sports like golf with the Saudi
live League you now have the Saudi
Football League led by Cristiano Ronaldo
but loads of top stars going out there
I'm a good friend of Cristiano and I've
been following this journey with him
with great Fascination it's taken a lot
of blow back from people you say we
shouldn't be allowing the Saudis or
other Middle Eastern countries who have
a bad human rights records to be doing
this to sport what's your view
yeah my relationship has been with uh
with Abu Dhabi in the UAE for years now
and uh if you look at what that royal
family has done with that country over
the last 50 years it's incredible
um and they were the first ones really
to do it they started getting involved
in sports and and saw the whole Sports
thing coming I mean UFC has been in
business with them
for like 15 years
um
and to be honest with you when the
hit the fan during covid these guys were
way ahead of the curve way ahead of you
know what was going on and and how to
test and how to create a true bubble but
do you have any do you have do you have
any moral qualms about the human rights
records of some of these countries or do
you think it should be just kept out of
sport that actually I mean I have a view
that almost every country if you put a
real forensic Gaze on them about reasons
for not to let them have sport on moral
grounds you'd end up having to play
everything in Iceland or Switzerland
yeah yeah I don't know that that's a
tough one I mean that that's a that's a
whole different subject and a whole
different conversation
um you know we we do business with UAE
these guys have always been great Stand
Up Guys I'm sure you can find some
issues with whatever you can find some
issues with with lots of different
companies that that that that uh do
business in the United States and
everywhere in the world when it comes to
Human Rights and what you think is right
and what you think is wrong
um
I I uh
am very comfortable sitting here today
telling you that uh my relationship with
the royal family of UAE has been amazing
they've never been anything but great to
us and our people
um you know
I respect them and I consider them
friends too
good evening I'm Fez Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only room for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean their Kinfolk
do you believe you can win this war he's
making me cry again they're trying to
force you out yes I feel betrayed keep
it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I honestly wish I'd never met
him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]
if we stopped producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I don't know you're probably going
to vote me after church
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass
thank you very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
when I'm in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drug you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored Dana White
one on one
there's been a lot of speculation about
a massive potential fight in the Octagon
between Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg
you've been quite excited about this uh
do you think it's going to happen do you
think you will be the guy to put it on
and how much money could it generate
well we were talking about that earlier
on I think that has uh Fallen apart I
think I think that uh you know had it
happened and had we moved forward and
done it it was it would have done a
billion dollars in Revenue
um and uh
that I don't know I mean if I knew the
answer to that I'd be Vince McMahon but
uh you know who wins and who loses I
don't determine they do but uh I tell
you this it would have been huge it
would have been the biggest fight in the
history of the world and no fight would
have uh you'd have had to have Trump
versus Putin to to uh to beat that
record are we going to see Conor
McGregor back in a high profile site
he is back in the gym he's training and
uh yeah I I expect to see Connor
fighting next year
does he matter that he's lost
a few big fights recently does that
impact on his ability to put bums on
seat sell tickets
well here's what happens Pearson I you
know this I'm sure you've seen this with
colleagues and friends and and people
that you know
um once a certain level of money
it was attained
you know to to to be the person that you
were coming up to be that hungry and and
work that hard and be that dedicated to
the sport or or whatever craft it is you
do money changes everything and Conor
McGregor has made that kind of money
um and it's not a knock it's just just a
fact I mean when we sold the company in
2016 it you know this was sort of like a
a Microsoft of fighting you know there
were a lot of people that made a lot of
money and a lot of people left and they
went and they went and retired or moved
on to uh you know you have to have a
certain
type of drive to make that kind of money
and that you've seen guys in this sport
when they make that kind of money you
know they'll fight
a lot less like Connor has or they go on
losing streaks because it's just you are
not that same person once you get that
kind of money you lose the edge
the hunger yeah yeah the the hunger and
the drive is not the same you know
everything Conor McGregor is the perfect
example everything that Conor McGregor
ever dreamed of and stuff he couldn't
possibly dream of in his life
he has right now you know
um and and it's and it's tough to be on
a yacht all summer and then say I gotta
get back in the gym and and start
grinding again and again it's not a
knock it's just it's it's the way it's
the way life is especially in the fight
business especially in the fight
business social media has been a massive
thing for you and you actually gave one
person some great advice because Dwayne
Johnson The Rock did not want to go on
to social media and you persuaded it
single-handedly he said you're mad you
should be on social media he's now the
most followed American man on Instagram
so I think the words he's looking for
are thank you Dana
yeah the rock didn't want to be on
social media and I said you're crazy I
said do you know how big you'll be on
social media and I kind of explained it
uh to him
from a business perspective on why he
should do it and I actually set him up
with my social media team and they they
got him started and got him going and I
mean the guy is an absolute Juggernaut
now on social media so yeah it's social
media I mean you've got kids I've got
kids social media has a lot of good
stuff about it there's no question
has some bad stuff it could be pretty
toxic a lot of kids suffer from anxiety
from the stuff that exists on social
media what do you think on the balance
sheet is it a false for good or not
yeah I think there's a lot of negative
things in this world that if you if you
focus on that type of stuff and if
you're not Tough Enough and if you're
not hard enough for it let me tell you
what if you if if your feelings get hurt
easily you should stay as far away from
social media as possible okay I actually
agree but
social media is one of the greatest
marketing tools of all time right and
what you have to understand is you have
to embrace the negativity too the
negative you can't just have you're
never going to be in a scenario anywhere
in life where everything is positive oh
everybody loves me and everybody's
saying great things about all the things
that I do it just it's impossible so to
if if that is even your mindset you're
way too soft for probably a lot of
things but to say that social media is
bad it's it's the same thing that that
they said about us when we were younger
that television was horrible for you my
God if you watch television this and
that and everything listen there's a lot
of bad things out there in the world if
you are soft and if you are a total wimp
you know forget about it everything's
gonna bother you everything's gonna hurt
your feelings and everything's going to
give you anxiety what do you what do you
say yourself up in a closet somewhere
and hide from the whole world you know
one day though it's so refreshing to
hear this because so few public figures
will actually say this stuff anymore
because they get terrified the
Brigade is going to cancel them for
saying things which are so obviously
true
and I just it's refreshing whenever I
hear you speak I think this guy just
says what he thinks and by the way I
agree with most of what you say
yeah so social media is the greatest
marketing tool in the world if you own a
business or you're you're aspiring to do
something uh you know and and get your
your image your product your whatever it
is out there you're insane not to be on
social media but don't go on social
media and thinking that it's gonna
here's the other thing that you have to
understand too about the negativity on
social media if you're out there looking
to promote something you have to embrace
the negativity because the negative
people are so loony they're so bad
nuts that these people will stay on
there all day fighting with everybody to
make it and it kicks you up into the
algorithm and actually makes your post
act more popular you know you this this
is what a lot of these big corporations
don't understand like these big
corporations want to we want to get into
social media and everything else well
you better get ready for some negativity
but most of them can't handle negativity
so that so they they try to stay away
from it we live in a hard world people
are mean and people say mean things and
people do mean things that's how that's
been that way since the beginning of
time and it's never going to change so
either toughen up or go hide somewhere
just get out of the way we're in a very
strange place at the moment in sport
where biological males are beginning to
dominate biological females in women's
sport because they identify as women
what do you think of that
I think you know exactly what I think of
that I think that you know let me put it
to you this way I have a daughter okay
and and uh
you know I I don't ever want to see a
day where somebody who is a biological
male is competing against my daughter so
yeah no I I think it's uh it's another
it's another nutty you know insane thing
that's happening in the world today you
know that we're all trying to deal with
and uh yeah I'm just glad there's no
some my daughter's a cheerleader so
she's not playing any competitive sports
but uh you know it hasn't happened in
the chair in the cheer world yet
I mean if your daughter wanted to be a
fighter what would you feel about that
because you put on some very very big
fights involving women I gotta be honest
I I never feel that comfortable watching
women smacking Seven Bells out of each
other I know it's hugely popular I know
they love doing it I know that some of
them become Superstars I make tons of
money but as the father of an 11 year
old girl myself I would never want to
see her do it how do you feel about if
your daughter wanted to
I famously got hammered uh like 10 years
ago saying women would never fight in
the UFC and then I met Ronda Rousey but
you have to understand the context at
the time I was trying to get people to
accept men fighting in a cage women
fighting in a cage I was like oh my God
this will be next to Impossible but if
you look at what we did almost
everything was impossible in building
this business to what we built it to
today but what I did learn is that these
were I never expected these women to be
as Technical and and as badass as they
have been and the answer to that
question is yes if my daughter wanted to
fight I would absolutely let her fight I
wouldn't stop my daughter from doing
anything or competing in anything that
you wanted to do I would actually be
very supportive and and and help in any
way that I possibly could who is the
greatest fighter of any kind that you've
ever seen
of any time in any sport anytime any
sport
it's so hard to put your thumb on it
because I think it's well let me let me
make it an easy question I'll make an
easy question if you could choose one
person in history
the same modern history last hundred
years to fight literally for your life
who would it be
oh God you know I'm a big Ali fan he was
so iconic and he changed so many things
uh in the world and culture and and uh
you know as far as racism and so many
different things go Ali was such a
massive figure in life you know not just
boxing
um
was he the greatest ever out of one of
the greatest humans ever that's a fact
but that's not the question as far as
you did lose three times I know
you you got me on this one I mean Jon
Jones who's in the UFC still has never
been beat this guy has beat everybody
and when you talk about real fighting
you know when you talk about who the
baddest man on the planet is when you
talk about that the real
definition of what that means you throw
two guys in a room and who comes out
yeah okay that's the baddest man on the
planet and it's it and and it is hard to
not say that Jon Jones is that guy right
now I want to come back and just uh
finally talk to you about your health
because you've had some pretty big
Health scares and a guy called Gary
Brecker who's going to join you has
pretty much I think you would say helps
save your life and we're going to talk
about how that's happened and why it had
to happen
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
part of my interview with USC president
Dana White and a special guest
so we've been joined Now by Gary
breckett I think the easiest thing Dana
explained to to the audience who Gary is
and why he's so important to you
yeah so Gary Brecker is a human
biologist and and I met him uh through
through a long time friend of mine so I
ended up finding out that he was a
mortality expert so
he could tell you when you were going to
die and he would be right within a month
or so I became obsessed with this so
that was all I cared about so he finally
talks me into coming out and he starts
going through my blood work and he
starts telling me everything that's
wrong with me with no medical history
whatsoever on me so this is kind of
blowing me away then he told me what was
wrong with my parents and he was right
so basically he ended up getting me and
he says to me
uh give me 10 weeks
I promise I'll change your life so I
said all right I'll commit 10 weeks to
this thing and to say that this guy has
changed my life is the understatement of
of of the century I mean I as I got to
the 10-week point I started to feel like
I was in my 30s again and now I've been
with him a year and a half
and I'm not kidding you I feel like I'm
in my 20s my level of productivity at
work my cognitive my physical I mean
just everything this guy is a genius
well before I come to Gary just quickly
how long did he say you had to live if
he hadn't changed things he yeah he gave
me 10.4 years and what's crazy about
that is he gave me 10 points he said if
you stay on this trajectory that you're
on you're going to live another 10.4
years and me and my wife both disagree
with him I actually think I wouldn't
have made it 10.4 years if I hadn't met
him let me bring in Gary so Gary I mean
that's one of the great marketing
pictures I've heard in a very short it
absolutely is right in a short nutshell
what have you done today to make him so
enthusiastic and to in his eyes prolong
his life
I mean so Dana had a common precursor
for cardiovascular disease called
metabolic syndrome it's actually the
leading cause of cardiovascular disease
which is the leading cause of death
worldwide and it's a combination of of
five things abdominal obesity low
healthy cholesterol low HDL cholesterol
elevated insulin and blood sugar
elevated cholesterol and hypertension
and to have any two of those five is
considered to have meta you know you're
considered to have metabolic syndrome
something you should get addressed it's
why I think everybody should get data on
their bodies he started exercising again
he went on a keto reset diet the
majority of what Dana did was really
what Dana did himself
um and one of the key things just
quickly Gary what were the key things
that Dana changed in terms of diet which
made a big difference so we did three
thing big things with Dana we did
hormone balance we did nutrient
deficiencies
um and we did glycemic control it
controls blood sugar so he went on a
strict
um keto reset diet which is a very
strict I call it a prescription keto
diet meaning you have to eat exactly
what is on this plan morning noon and
night for 10 weeks or this situation
could get a whole lot worse so we went
on a strict heated diet he had a strict
exercise and workout routine it's
fascinating I've got a I've got to
unfortunately wrap it up it's
fascinating I don't know whether to see
you or not Gary because what I don't
want to hear is you look at me and go
appears unfortunately uh you're leaving
us next Tuesday
thank you
I can fix that and you know we'll push
it out a couple of thousand Tuesdays
it's been brilliant uh honestly I've had
such a fascinating time going over your
life your extraordinary career your
amazing achievement with UFC my son's I
started with this are going to end it
they're all massive UFC fans they're all
very excited about this interview the
first question they're going to ask is
Dad how did you do did Dana think you're
any good that's all they'll care about
so what's the verdict
incredible great interview it was a
pleasure and uh tell your boys thank you
I really appreciate the support Dana
White what a pleasure thank you very
much indeed
likewise thank you
well that's it from me and from Dana
White what a fascinating guy and a
fascinating interview that's all for
tonight Keep It Uncensored good night
foreign
[Music]
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about left he wants NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board should
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way T KTM that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
[Music]